[Applause]  [Music]  and i will faithfully execute the office  of president of the united states office  of president of the united states  hi kamala davey harris do solemnly swear  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  you are stealing my house and if i don't  steal it someone else is gonna steal it  [Music]  um  to the next generation of dreamers if we  can do this  just imagine what you can do  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  so  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  there is no planet b  there is no planet blah blah blah blah  blah blah  [Music]  the emergence of the omicron variant  should be a wake-up call to the world  that vaccine inequality cannot be  allowed to continue  until everyone is vaccinated  everyone will continue to be at risk  [Music]  you